hi guys I'm Eric Voss and HBO has
announced that Game of Thrones season 7
will be premiering July 16th and they
made this announcement with a Facebook
live event where tens of thousands of us
watched a big block of ice melt slowly
revealing the dates no not the worst way
of spent an afternoon and of course this
awesome teaser now it was mostly just
iconic lines from past seasons played
over cool-looking imagery of all the
house digital's attacking each other but
I think there could be some clues hidden
in here that might hint at things that
we'll see in season 7 so let's break it
down I know what my father won what he
did I know to match a man tonight okay
so here we see the three dragon heads of
the Targaryen sigil as we hear Daenerys
his line from season five where she
admitted to Tyrion her father's fault
really the first time she said anything
against her family's history I know what
my father would what he did I know the
Mad King and his name also this scene
ends with Daenerys is break the wheel
line that we hear at the end of the
season we also hear the voice of her
father the Mad King as these screams
burn them all which remember were his
last words before he was slain by Jaime
Lannister as the Baratheon army invaded
King's Landing
we actually saw this event through
brands eyes as he had that vision last
season but I think the point of this is
to remind us that before Daenerys can
invade Westeros to reclaim the Iron
Throne she's going to have to come to
terms with the scorched Targaryen legacy
that her father left behind and that
might mean that she has to revisit her
birthplace on Dragonstone and I love how
the visuals here kind of play into that
with these dragons made out of stone
that looks very much like dragon glass
obsidians one of the few things that can
kill White Walkers and large quantities
of dragon glass are known to be found on
Dragonstone which I think could end up
being a major plot point in this season
all right moving on
every Targaryen I get my
get it bringing in cake cake ha ha so in
this section right after the mad Kings
burned them all we see and hear the
historical events that came right after
that moment Robert Baratheon symbolized
by the SAG ending the Targaryen rule the
dragon and over this we hear Roberts
line from season one kill every
Targaryen I get my hands on and when you
think about it Robert obsession with
murdering every last Targaryen relative
was actually pretty catastrophic for him
because it drove a wedge between him and
Ned Stark resulting in Ned resigning as
hand of the king Jaime Lannister feeling
safe to attack Ned and then that ensuing
injury to weaken Ned physically and
weaken both him and Robert politically
as the Lannisters took power which is
why right after that we see the
Lannister lion turned on the Baratheon
stag along with Circe's ominous season 1
line to Joffrey everyone who isn't odd
isn't it and then we see the stark
wolf's head howling pain as we hear
Joffrey give the command that proved
fatal for his own reign in a lot of ways
executing Ned Stark and sending Westeros
into war I also like the way they
include the sound of cyril and sword as
a cut through ned snack so really this 8
second summarized all the major events
of season 1 so to just watch that and
before i move on we see the tentacles of
the gradually squid constrict as we hear
the voice of veil on Greyjoy as he
lecture his son Theon in season 2 yeah
I'm bald
we're not subject well slaves we do not
plow the fields or pulling in the mine
we take our dollars and don't forget
we're doing massive naval battle between
the fleet of your own Greyjoy and the
combined fleet of Daenerys including the
Dothraki Martel's Tyrells and Theon and
Yara so obviously the mics and the pride
of the Greyjoy's is going to be a big
deal if we head into season 7 right
moving on
regarde dancing attitude paladin be
still another second Thursday of the
house
protects the Seven Kingdoms okay so in
this section we see the big political
shifts of season two and three as the
Greyjoy's squid brings down the stark
wolf on one side as Theon did when he
sacked Winterfell while on the other
side we hear the voice of Roose Bolton's
when he betrayed the Starks at the red
wedding along with Catelyn scream of
defeat amounted to and there a god and
at first I thought this was another lion
but on the second glance I think this is
a bear the sigil of the house Mormont of
Jorah and little Leanna Thane now this
is interesting because the more mods are
the only minor house to be featured in
the season like we don't see anything
from house Aaron or Martell pray or
Bolton for example and maybe it's just
hard to show a bird a son spear a flayed
man or a pair of castles duking it out
with all these other animals but still I
think this is the clue that the more
mobs will be pretty instrumental to the
end game of this series like with Lady
Leanna helping Jon maintain his control
the north as docking to north but also
Jorah possibly headed to Oldtown to heal
its greyscale and work with Sam on a way
to defeat the White Walkers I kind of
talked about some theories on that my
other students on prediction videos also
there's this awesome shot of the Rhodes
and thorny stems of the Tyrell family as
we hear alehna Tyrell pretty much admit
to Margaery and season four that she was
the one who poisoned Joffrey so that a
Tyrell could ever take the throne you
don't think I'd let you marry that beast
deal but then shortly after that we see
the green wildfire overtake the Rhodes
reflexing Circe's epic blowing up with a
Sept of Baelor in the season six finale
killing off the Tyrell bloodline and
over this wheat here where that hostile
takeover let Cersei on the Iron Throne
as the new hand of the king Clyburn
crowned her at the end of that episode
protector of the Seven Kingdoms all
right let's move on
[Music]
there was a big tsunami it wins on top
and that one's on top and on and on it's
been
crushing this on the ground okay so here
we return to that season five scene with
Daenerys as she describes the conflicts
between the major families of Westeros
as focused on a wheel that she intends
to break I'm going to break the wheel
and I just love all this plays out
visually with each of these digital's
crumbling like mountains in an
earthquake but it's interesting how the
first one we see breaking is Daenerys
his own house the Targaryen dragons and
I think this indicates that the cyclical
political struggle between the families
will indeed crumble but Daenerys will be
a victim in that collapse so it won't be
her necessarily breaking this wheel
causing the end of human history instead
the visuals make it clear that winter is
causing it look at the falling snow it's
the cold making everything shatter like
when it gets really cold and ice can
burst pipes and trees and stuff so this
is a cool visual representation of the
Game of Thrones promise from its very
first scenes that winter is coming and
White Walkers will consume this heady
game of Thrones
alright moving on to this final section
thanks big is coming for all of us
there's only one war the punishing the
Gribble
and it is he
[Music]
okay so this last part contains the
first new lines that we've heard from
season seven same thing is coming :
although that first that might have been
from third Davos I'm not exactly sure
who's gonna be one wool
[Music]
the grandpa
by the sound of this line it seems like
John is trying to convince someone to
rally to his cause to arm up against the
White Walkers and I think this will be a
huge part of John's mission in season
seven along with convincing the rest of
Westeros that White Walkers are actually
real and not the mythical bogeyman that
most people assume they are and I just
love how the editing makes it appear as
if the pieces of the shattered family
sigils fallen into place to form this
spiral pattern now remember last season
we learned that the spiral pattern is
something that the White Walkers do to
recall their creation by the children of
the forest it's a symbol of their
history
so really it's kind of like the White
Walkers are destroying all of the
Westeros we family sigils to create
their own family schedules which is
exactly what the White Walkers are all
about remember they destroy humans who
create their own armies and they take
human babies to create their own white
Walker baby which is why it's doubly
cool that this spiral glows blue or Mane
the blue eye of a white Walker so
basically if you look at this teaser in
totality it shows the Wars of men
throughout the game of Thrones season
Robert's rebellion the war of the five
kings Thirsty's coup d'etat and the
upcoming Targaryen restoration but then
all of them get torn down by winter
their pieces left to rot and then
resurrected as White Walkers so even
without any footage this teaser is very
cool and I really love the promise that
sets up for season seven and yes July
16th too long the wait and the adil only
these seven episodes but it sounds like
each of them will be 20 minutes or so
longer and with so few episodes left I
really don't think there's going to be
any more time for filler so hopefully no
more endless chats between Sam and Gilly
now I've made two other videos going
through all my predictions for Game of
Thrones season seven so definitely check
those out I cover pretty much everything
but if you have any other predictions or
theories of your own please weigh in the
comments and please like this video and
subscribe to new rockstars and share
this video around you can also
contribute to us on patreon big thanks
to all of our current patrons especially
Kelly hopper you can hit me up on
twitter at EA vas if any thoughts do you
have about Game of Thrones or call a new
rock stars on Twitter at new rock stars
for updates on our videos alright thanks
for watching bye